protocols let's see can we remember we
looked at this briefly last year
what's a protocol protocol ah good it's
a set of rules everyone needs to agree
on it right like say the Kyoto Protocol
it's like okay every we'll set up a set
of rules everyone has to abide by it
okay or ghost Protocol or whatever okay
so why do we need a protocol on a
network on a network why would we need a
protocol where data has to be sent back
and forth any suggestions okay good good
having no protocol is a little bit like
everyone speaking a different language
okay I love you ever to communicate you
with you very effectively if we would
have the same language even apart from
that you're apart from what you want to
communicate being functionally remember
for example let's think that suited the
ring network I told you before that in a
a ring network we usually have this
thing called a token right which gets
passed around and like a train which
takes on passengers where you are data
you stick it on there and then off it
goes around the network in fact this is
so common that they often call it's not
a ring topology but a token ring okay
no how do we govern who gets the data
and how you know arrives of the right
destination for instance and we can have
that the data on their right has an
address okay and as it goes around from
node to node each node checks what's
written on the front okay it says okay
this is my address well this is not my
address therefore I should open it or
not open it so that protocol there which
governs the the kind of address that
it's got that needs to be agreed upon in
all of the by all the nodes right
because otherwise what if two people
think they have the same address right
because they haven't decided on the
protocol for determining address
okay then two sets of people gonna be
ugly the same stepdaughter you're gonna
get really confused um you need a
protocol on a network to make the
network actually achieve its purpose
okay that's the key thing now protocols
from talking about they make sure that
people understand what's going on they
make sure that people are the Dada gets
to its destination okay but there's a
specific part of network protocols which
is very interesting on its own and
that's what we called collision handling
we mentioned data collisions very very
briefly yesterday which topology what we
talking about that had data collisions
to be told remember remember one of the
early ones Jack do you remember bus as
he's happy right now why would a bus
topology have collisions on it and
therefore we need a protocol for
collisions why would it need them what
is it about the bus topology as opposed
to say they're in topology but then
necessitates this that needs rules for
how collisions work
they would help them out and what you've
got is a common space where all the data
is traveling alone right sir in a bus
topology you have collisions therefore
you want to learn how to handle them
right so the protocol has to include
rules for that where it is on the ring
you're not gonna have collisions so yeah
I mean you suppose you could have a
protocol for the collisions but they'll
never happen so why bother okay so
that's why it's needed for a bus
topology but not for a ring to party now
I'm gonna describe for you
one kind of protocol which has in it a
set of rules for handling collisions
it's got a a long terrible awful name
okay but it's long and terrible and
awful because it's very very descriptive
okay so its acronym is CSMA /c d okay
and what it stands for of is included in
the newsperson
I'm gonna try and describe and to find
this protocol based on the individual
parts okay so here's the member so I'm
gonna start with the middle M a the M a
stands for multiple access this is sort
of another way of saying this protocol
design for buses okay it's designed for
networks where multiple people are
accessing the same kind of space okay so
that's why this protocol doesn't make
sense on a ring because you don't have
media connections that multiple people
can access right in a ring only one
person can access this and send along it
right only one person can access this
and send along it so it's not multiple
access this is for multiple access now
how does this multiple access system
work well it starts with what we call a
carrier signal carrier signal
this is a signal that tells computers I
can carry your data
hence carry a signal okay what is the
carrier signal now you can actually do a
carrier signals all the time probably if
you've got a home phone okay what
happens when you pick up your home phone
when you want to start dialing there's
not no sound there's actually a sound
there we give it a name what's it called
what's when you pick it up it's sort of
like a sort of a hum we call it a dial
tone right a dial tone what what does a
dial tone mean it means you can dial and
it'll work
it'll do something it'll accomplish
something I can receive your data and
send it off to where it's supposed to be
the dial tone is a kind of carrier
signal okay and you know you need it
because if you picked up the phone and
there was no sound nothing what would
that mean over that indicate you as
disconnected probably your phone's not
plugged in or like there's been a
blackout so somewhere along the cables
right you're not getting the carrier
signal that's being sent to you okay so
there is a carrier signal adult and I'm
gonna illustrate this in a minute well
this last one on the end the slash means
width and the CD stands for collision
detection collision detection okay so
this has rules for working out what does
it look like when data collides okay it
can detect it and then it can deal with
it okay so